i am here in italy but my thoughts are
in afghanistan every day i think of how
they are
what they are doing and how i can help
them i feel really bad about what is
happening in our country we never
thought something like this could ever
happen the taliban are going to every
home to take revenge they shoot the
people who cooperated with the
government or other nations the taliban
has not changed all the world is looking
at them so they are trying to hold back
once they're out of the spotlight
they're going to act even worse than
before they will never change
i have two sisters a brother and some
nephews and nieces who are in my country
they want to leave they are scared
they're afraid of dying since all this
happened i do not know if i'm sleeping
or i'm awake i do not know what i'm
doing i go to work every day and after
my shift i go to see people i hope can
help my family
you